So here it's a chart we've seen a version
of before where we're looking at a
wide range of different types of hazard.
All of the things that you wind
up being concerned about is,
is something going to cause cancer,
ozone depletion and
global warming explode,
break into flames when he act and corrode
my skin, et Cetera, et Cetera, et Cetera,
et cetera. Um, all of those things, as,
as we know you could draw direct lines
to all of these physical chemical
properties, whether or not something's
volatile, whether or not something is, uh,
is prone to react with positive
charges on negative charges.
All of these, these properties
and I should say combinations,
combinations of properties,
properties in combination.
I'm going to tell you whether or not
this stuff is going to be good for you or
deadly. Um, you know,
it's also going to tell you whether
or not it's going to be useful in a
commercial sense or uh, or useless. So,
uh, and we come back to something that
we've been saying all semester long.
What is it that,
that chemists do?
They design and manipulate
and exploit this stuff.
So if you can design and
use and explain this stuff,
then you have a tremendous
influence over that stuff. You know,
I often say that in the same way that no
one has a greater impact on how a book
is going to affect its reader,
then the author,
nobody can have a greater impact
over whether or not, uh, uh,
a building is going to, you know, look
aesthetically pleasing, then it's,
then it's architect.
No one is going to have a
greater influence on the
ultimate consequences for a
chemical than the molecular designer
that's at the design stage that
you have maximum influence.
So I said this is a relatively new
endeavor in a relatively
new scientific endeavor.
Why would that be?
Doesn't that seem counterintuitive?
When I talk to young students,
uh,
elementary school students, uh,
great. Um, so you'll tell them, well,
we are doing this thing called green
chemistry and Liz has making all of these
materials and things so that they're
not going to hurt you or hurt the
environment and they look at you and they
blink what they're widely utilized and
they think, yeah, haven't been doing
this all along. You're kidding me.
And so why not?
Um,
generally it's because of what
we knew and what we didn't know.
So we talked about toxicology evolving
from a descriptive science, uh,
where basically, um, you know,
we've tested things usually on,
on animals and you look to see
what the consequences were.
And knowing that something is toxic is
very different from knowing why and how
something is toxic. Once you know the
why and the how of something being toxic,
then that gives you design handles.
So as it emerged from a,
from a descriptive science
to a mechanistic science
and mechanism of action,
the molecular understanding
of what's going on,
then all of a sudden you hell
of all these design handles,
you actually know how to modify
things so that they can be, uh, less,
less toxic in many ways. Uh, uh,
green chemistry is a,
is often called preventative toxicology.
So we moved from describing
to predicting to preventing,
okay.
So how did we emerge in getting
this understanding? Well,
one of the places is from
the pharmaceutical industry.
The pharmaceutical industry for decades
now is a generated a treasure trove of
insight on the,
the biological interactions with
these molecules that we make. Okay.
How they're going into our bodies, how
they interact with, uh, various receptors.
But there's a difference between
pharmaceutical chemicals and industrial
chemicals.
For instance,
pharmaceuticals are supposed
to be biologically active.
That's what makes them definitionally a
pharmaceutical and active pharmaceutical
ingredient.
The vast majority,
I often just say 99% of
all of those chemicals,
of all of chemicals that
aren't pharmaceuticals
usually have no intentional
biological activity. We can talk
about the exceptions if you want,
but generally speaking, industrial
chemicals are meant to be, you know,
to be a lacquer.
I meant to be a color I met.
They're not meant to have biological
activity with pharmaceuticals.
Definitionally the performance of the
chemical is related to its biological
activity including reduced toxicity
performance has generally been a whole
separate mindset in the development
of industrial chemicals.
So function and performance was
not defined as being part of,
um, uh, it was not defined as
including toxicity or hazard.
It was you had function and
performance and then, oh yeah.
And this other consideration you'd have
this thing to worry about rather than
having it being merged.
Um,
relatively the volume of pharmaceuticals
is minuscule by to industrial
chemicals.
You,
you might literally have billions and
billions of pounds of an industrial
chemical where a very,
you know,
a very large volume pharmaceutical
might be a ton because why,
you know, the dosage is
milligrams per pill. Uh,
where uh,
and with pharmaceuticals you
have a well defined use scenario,
you're going to put it in a pillar
injection or something like that or an
inhaler. And it's going to go into
a person, et Cetera, et Cetera,
where the same molecule that might be
a polymer building block might be a
solvent,
might be a other kind of a reactant.
And you can have a wide range of
scenarios crossing all kinds of different
sectors,
all kinds of different life cycles
and end of end of life considerations.
So the um,
the whole green chemistry molecular design
element steel's liberally from all of
those lessons in all of the fundamentals
that pharmaceuticals gave us and
translates them into the vast
majority of other chemicals,
the industrial chemicals. But it's a
little bit different. I'm going to,
and this is important,
it's taking the lessons of pharmaceutical
science and turning it on its head.
It's really looking at
the whole thing backwards.
Because when you're designing a drug,
you want to make sure that that
drug is able to get into your body,
cross unnecessary biological membranes,
make its way to find a receptor,
um, uh, intact and in
the form that will react,
bind with that receptor,
carry out.
It's it's therapeutic function,
and then be released from the body
with green chemistry,
molecular design for reduced toxicity.
You want to use all of those same tools
to make sure that that molecule can
never get into the body, can never cross
the necessary biological membranes,
can never bind to a particular receptor
that would cause a toxic effect,
and it gets out of the body
as quickly as possible. Okay?
So you have to have the same
understanding, the same tools,
but use it in a a very different way.